All right, thanks everybody for today's Zoom call and we got a bunch of questions to go over.
And always I like to begin it with make sure you do look at our blog posts.
We are adding stuff to that on a regular basis.
So click on anything on our website that little looking glass thing on our website magnifying glass and you can search pages and blog.
Post pages anywhere on our site for any topic.
So make sure you do look at that when you're trying to come up with your answers.
If you can't find something, then of course you send a question to the cutters clinic or the info cutters clinic or your liaison.
So we could get it on the next Zoom call.
So let's jump right into the questions.
So question number one, do you know what hydroxy citrate is?
What are its benefits for breast cancer? Are there any negative effects?
First of all, start with the last part, I don't know of any negative effects of hydroxy citrate.
So it is something that anybody could take typically the studies for hydroxy citrate are with using it with low pay low pay a low pollic acid.
So using a low pollic acid with hydroxy citrate are really where all the studies are that I have seen on it.
But it's something that can help decrease the glucose carrying capacity of any cancer.
And a cancer is driven mainly through glycolysis. That's what this really shines or has the ability to shine.
So typically this like this is a product of hydroxy citrate that we carry.
It's carcidia product and this is the chromate product in it.
And it's typically used for weight loss. So this has got chromium picolidate with it as well.
Chromium picolidate will help with glucose carried capacity and with appetite control.
And the hydroxy citrate in the form of carcidia that's where it's found, actually, is what can help decrease glucose use in the cell.
So in a sense, you can help lose weight. So it's typically sold as a weight loss product. It's a supplement. It's not a prescription.
So you can buy it any where you can buy it on our store.
If you're taking another product with alphalopalic acid, you certainly don't need to add any extra alphalopalic acid.
Just take about the same time as all. This is the alphalopac acid from designs for health.
But our burger clear also has alphalopac acid. So if you're taking that or a different brand, you'll have that side covered.
But that's what that is for is to help decrease glucose usage in the cell.
So in a sense, it could kind of like you could say kind of like a natural metform and again, it's typically used for weight loss could be used for diet type to diabetes to so it can be a good product to take.
Next question. What'd it be good to get an echo to machine for home use that would add hydrogen to drinking water?
Is there a specific one you'd recommend? So this is the echo brand machine that this person is talking about. These are good machines that I have heard from.
We had a doctor that worked for we doctor alderman she was working with this company for a little bit of time. I don't know whatever happened to that.
But I know she uses hydrogen water machine. It can be beneficial. There's these other type of units that you could use a nasal cannula and you could get straight hydrogen breathing it in.
So you're absorbing hydrogen in through your alveolar spaces in your lungs. The purpose of adding age to hydrogen to your body is it can be an antioxidant. So the benefits are antioxidant properties.
Some people don't want to sit there and do this. You're supposed to do these machines for like a half an hour a day. Some people don't want to sit there and do this for half an hour a day.
This way, you're actually you connect this to your this unit to your drinking water in your kitchen and then you end up with hydrogenated water that you're drinking. I don't think it makes the water taste any different, but you're absorbing the hydrogen in your gut.
So it can be beneficial that way. So yes, it's still it's just another thing that a person can do.
And so it's something that a person can think of is it going to make drastic changes in a person's life. I don't know, but it does add another level of antioxidants to your protocol.
And don't you don't want to be doing this. If you're doing chemotherapy, you would lay off of doing any hydrogen inhalation or hydrogen water for the 48 hours after high be chemotherapy.
So you would treat this as an antioxidant that you're going to stay away from.
48 hour period. Are you familiar with Cortif? Bob was told this might be better for him that taking a steroid long term.
So Cortif is is a medical prescription drug of cortisol, which actually is a more natural steroid, you could say.
It has pros and cons, and I can't tell a person understand just so everybody hears me again, I can't legally tell you to take or not to take a drug.
That is a prescription drug. I can make recommendations that over the counter things, but I can't tell you take prescription drug or to go off a prescription. So if you're going to choose to go off something that your prescribing position has given you that you have to talk to that prescribing position or talk to a different prescribing position.
Just legalities there, okay, but the pros and cons of cortisol, the negative, the positive thought behind this, whoever told this person, that's the positive thought is that a cortisol is a more natural Cortif is mimicking cortisol, it's a more natural steroid.
Therefore, it's maybe better than taking a synthetic steroid.
And the answer to that was maybe that is true. The negative is is that Cortif being a cortisol derived steroid can have a negative effect of basically shutting down your adrenals.
Your adrenals and your thyroid, your pituitary, work on a negative feedback loop. So when you take an exogenous from the outside thyroid medication, your thyroid gland basically shuts down because your body senses all this T3 or T4 in your bloodstream.
This thyroid, you could take a vacation, you're doing such a great job to the thyroid basically shuts down production.
Problem with that is that now you become dependent upon that thyroid medication. Now in times with thyroid issues that could be that could be necessary because that person has low thyroid production, they have poshimoto's.
There's different issues where it makes sense to go on thyroid medication, but when you go on a cortisol medication, you will do the same thing, you'll have a negative feedback loop where you'll shut down your adrenal glands.
And it tends to be very difficult to get them kicked back in gear. So I'm not a big fan of that.
A bunch of questions in this quote, this slide here, can I have Fuji water, can I drink Fuji water answer, yes, you can.
Next question, still have white on my tongue, not clear yet, is my gut still off.
White on your tongue can mean candida issues can mean an imbalance in your in your microbiota, you have a microbiota in your mouth also not just in your gut can be off with microbiota in your mouth, it can be something you're taking can be a medication you're using.
There's too many your sands and butts with that question because there's too many moving parts. So it would require a more unique answer so we might have to do a consult about that specifically.
Next question I drink about 64 ounces of water, but my mouth is dry skin is dry, what can I do.
Most people think that your skin is really dry or your mouth is dry because you're dehydrated there can be some truth to that.
But there's a couple sides to this coin, a person can over hydrate as well.
Over hydrate your you're going to flush out electrolytes and you need electrolytes in your system, which are simply minerals in your system for you to be able to hold minerals hold water in your system.
So if you flush out your electrolytes, you won't be able to hold water and you're drinking all this water, but you're actually dehydrated because you're drinking too much water sounds like a little oxymoron, but actually you could kill yourself by drinking too much water.
How do you possibly kill yourself for drinking too much water because you blown up and you know because you're basically dehydrated yourself you flush out all your electrolytes.
And you could have you could like instantly die if you drink 10 12 gallons of water today, so that is your your mineral levels cut down your potassium level drops you go into hallucination and you die so could a person be drinking too much water.
Yes, that's a possibility. So that's one possibility is that 64 ounces of water for you is too much you're drinking too much water you need to cut that half for a while.
Make sure you have good electrolytes meeting you get minerals from your food. So if you're getting eating good foods and good vegetables, especially then you don't have to worry necessarily about having to go take minerals.
You're already taking minerals that you've got that covered, but I'd start by just cutting that in half.
The other thing that could cause there's other things that could cause dry mouth so lots of things that could cause dry mouth that that can be due to, like I said in the last question, your microbiota beat off it could be due to medication that's the number one cause of dry mouth dry skin is less.
A dehydration issue and it's more fat issue so make sure you're getting enough good fats in your body. So are you using coconut oil are you using some fish oil if that's that's what you're taking think about the fat consumption that you're taking are you getting enough good fats.
Next question, what I do in animal every day I do not have formed stools is that okay. The yes, that is okay. So the purpose of doing it animal every day is not so that you're, you know, you're moving your balls it's that you're stimulating your parasympathetics and that's the most important thing.
So you want to stimulate your parasympathetics as much as you can and you see coffee animals is the way to go for that.
Question chatted and how do you feel about reverse osmosis water so reverse osmosis is really good at taking out toxins that you can't get out any other way.
So like heavy metals and different things like that that are difficult to get out with any charcoal type filter reverse osmosis will get those out lots of times even distillation will not remove heavy metals so if you're concerned about heavy metals in your water.
Then reverse osmosis is reverse osmosis is the best way to go to get rid of everything people argue that reverse osmosis is not good because you take out all the minerals well.
The truth is you're not drinking water for the minerals the minerals that are in the water are not necessarily good minerals for you anyhow their soil based minerals that you are not really well absorbed in the first place so they're I don't see the negative effects of.
Reverse osmosis like other people do isn't just doesn't make any sense you don't eat dirt you eat plants that's where you get your minerals plants take.
Well soil based minerals and they convert them to a double bonded.
I mean, acid.
Keylation and that's what you're supposed to be eating you don't eat you don't eat soil based minerals.
So reverse osmosis is a way to go for water filtration if you want yes.
My neuropathy is bad my skin hurts and is burdened like when you're sick it's gotten a lot worse the last year what can I do about this so first thing you want to do with neuropathy is try to discover why so well I already know why I got neuropathy it's because I did chemo so if you have chemo therapy.
So if you have chemo therapy.
Derived neuropathy that's one thing so we know we had damaged because of exposure to chemo therapy so you had a damaged from exposure to a toxin a toxic substance.
Yes, using a product using something like the rebuilder this is the picture of the rebuilder can be really helpful with that.
Using your ion pro wave can be helpful pulling out any toxins especially down at the feet from chemo therapy can be extremely helpful so that's why we recommend you use the ion pro wave especially if you're doing chemo therapy or you have something like this.
neuropathy if you have diabetic neuropathy that's another thing so.
So whatever you have a symptom you don't just want to treat the symptom you want to find out why so if you want to treat the reason why you have the neuropathy that's the first part of this question it's chemotherapy you try to detox the chemotherapy if it's diabetic induced neuropathy you treat the diabetes and you get the blood sugar down.
But then to treat the neuropathy itself neuropathy is certain fibers neuro fibers that are dying so you'll get the tingly tingly paid and then you'll get birdie paid and then pretty soon you won't have any paid at all you would have any feeling your feet and that's what you can trip and fall a lot because you don't feel where your feet are in space.
Well the rebuilder is a little tool that is not the whole lot different size of that if I could blow this picture up that's about how the size of it in real life and it's meant to be able to fit in your pocket and use like a tens unit if you need to but the best use of this is it comes with.
Electrons that connect to the front like a tens unit but you use the rubber electrons and you put them in water and you put your feet in water or your hands in water whatever you're going to treat.
And you turn it up and it feels like a really strong tingle and it's at the frequency it's electrical stimulation at the frequency of the nerve growth.
So this is a medically approved device it's FDA approved device with Medicare.
So if you did get a prescription they might even pay for it but you have to find a doctor that will prescribe it.
You can go to rebuildermenicleink.com and you can search for them I think they're nine hundred to thirteen hundred dollars for the device don't tell them but we sell them at our cost on our website I think they're seven eighty five or something sold at our cost so you can buy them directly from us on our store.
If you did this every day we've seen people we've used this device for gosh ten years with people with neuropathy from all different types and it's really worked really well.
You just have to do it every day if you can and people do get better so it's really a great device we used to use it in the clinic for people we saw more people in the clinic and saw more people of different with diabetes and stuff so it's a great device for neuropathy.
People in radiation on my anal area a lot of swelling on the outside is going down but on the inside they're swelling is still there in the last few weeks.
The bowel with this happens to be sore and sometimes bleeds lots of pain in the anal area what can we do do a set of conversation with the patient with similar issues and this is something that I would say I would try this first.
This is an article cream I'm sorry we don't sell this so you have to search for this so you could get article in an herbal form and you could get article in a homeopathic form this is a homeopathic article.
And this is a cream so it's meant to be topical for pain relief so arnica is a great pain relief or problem is is that a lot of arnica creams will also have menthol in it you certainly wouldn't want to put menthol down in that area so look for one that doesn't have menthol this one I just searched for does not have menthol we don't carry this but it's something you can look for other things that you can think of is topical.
Curcumin with a curcumin cream you can make up your old curcumin cream or we have a curcumin cream that's something to think about to so things like that something that's going to be anti inflammatory directly to the area I would start with something like this if it was me question about deep tissue massage patient normally does this but I recommended that they switch to more gentle massage.
And when can they go back to a deep tissue massage well you a person can do deep tissue massage when they have cancer it's just that you just have to use some level of common sense as well so there's massage therapists that still do really heavy Swedish massage with cancer patients but they stay away from the cancer site itself that make sense.
It really partly is very uniquely dependent upon the person because if you're doing deep tissue if you're used to doing deep tissue massage on a regular basis.
Then it makes more sense that you could continue it regardless whether you just got a diagnosis of cancer if it's something new to you that I would not suggest you go start jumping into deep tissue massage you're going to move a lot of toxins that you could make yourself sicker.
But if it's something you've done on a regular basis and it's really helped you like this person I would just scale back a little bit let your massage therapist know that you have cancer.
There is in many massage massage schools there's trading for cancer massages so ask if your massage therapist has had that trading.
I used to have a massage therapist that worked for me that we did massages and she actually went back took a course on cancer massage and got certified cancer massage I know that's available in Minnesota.
So it might be available in other states so do ask your massage therapist if they're certified in cancer massage and then they will know things to stay away from with that next question.
What do you mean by give it to God am I ready I am ready to give up so it's all at his hands does this mean I do nothing.
Great question was more of a theological question and I like theological questions so I'm going to jump into this so mean in my mind what it means to give things to God is technically something that we are supposed to do on a regular basis we're supposed to give our life is not ours anymore we have been bought with the price and our life is his.
So when we talk about giving our life to God turning it over surrendering our will to his this isn't something that should be done just because we have a crisis this is something that was is supposed to be done on a daily basis that's part of our walk of sanctification with our heavenly father we're turning our life over to him all of our struggles all of our joys all of our happiness everything is his.
So when we give our life to Christ when he becomes our savior at our Lord then he's responsible for things in our life doesn't mean we do nothing no he there's a work to be done certainly in this life but he annoys us unto these good works so we do need to have that relationship this is the biggest struggle that we have with patients they're trying to work through.
We're trying to work through a decision making process in their life maybe it's a big decision whether they should do chemo or whether they should do surgery or what they should be doing whether they should buy a house whether they should get married to this person these are great big giant decisions how do we make those decisions well most the time we make those decisions totally in our flesh we make those decisions by way you know the good and the bad and there's nothing wrong with doing that you put the pros on one side of the page and the
cons on the other side of the page and you write your list and if there's more pros than cons that you choose that specific decision we are called to use wisdom throughout scripture we're called to use wisdom throughout scripture it says we're not supposed to be ignorant and Hosea says my children perish for lack of knowledge because they have rejected knowledge I have rejected them.
So he's talking in Hosea about they've rejected knowledge I'm God and the desire to walk in his ways but we could equate that we suffer because of foolish things we do about knowledge in our environment and stuff too but ultimately the bottom line is we're supposed to be seeking after him constantly that's what are my responsibility as a believer if I call myself a Christian that's not simply because I'm not going to do that.
I prayed this prayer one time or got baptized or went through canachism that doesn't make me save it's that I'm committed my life to Jesus Christ on a daily basis and that's the walk of sanctification that we're all called to it's not one act that we did in the past and now we're okay and we can live our life any foolish way we want to the responsibility still falls back at me.
To keep and work towards and strive towards that relationship with him and that is a daily that's a that's really that's my first responsibility in my daily walk am I reading my scripture of my listening to good theology and and good theological books that's deepening my relationship with Christ and giving me a greater hunger and thirst for him and his righteousness on a daily basis.
And when I don't do that it's evident in my life it's evident in my life in ways to me meaning that I don't feel that connection I feel more lost I feel more confused I it's harder for me to make bigger decisions.
And it's evident in other people I you know maybe my language is good maybe I'm crappier more often maybe I react to situations that I should react to other people can see the evidence of my deep relationship with Christ or my lack thereof so it's not whether I say I'm a Christian or I go to church every Sunday and Sunday night and Wednesday and I'm you know lead Bible study and
to work with the youth none of that really makes any difference sometimes God calls us to those things and that's great but that doesn't that doesn't make you have a deeper relationship with him that's a personal thing that you have to strive for and work towards on a daily basis that is a work we're not saved through works we're saved through grace but we're saved unto to good works.
And those good works are various things maybe helping other people and such but they also are working and striving to keep that relationship with him so when we give it to God and we turn our life over to God that's a daily walk and a daily step it doesn't stop you don't just do it once and I gave my life to God and now everything's going to be hunky-dory you know he doesn't promise things to be hunky-dory anyhow if you read scripture you promise is not going to do it.
The scripture you promise is that you're going to go through persecutions and struggles and divisions and all sorts of problems for his name sake and we have to be willing to do that and that's the biggest thing so when the deeper relationship I know personally and if I have what I'm walking with the Lord that I personally don't worry about as many things as I worry about in my flesh.
If I find my fleshly anxiety rising up it's because I'm not giving it over to Christ if I find my fleshly anger at the world situation rising up it's because I'm not giving it over to Christ so whatever you're fleshly weakness is maybe it's anxiety over your cancer maybe it's anger at you know what's going to happen in the world in Canada right now or whatever maybe it's some you know.
Whatever it is for you that is just a sign so take that side and go I need to get back in my scripture again I need to get back seeking him and it starts with asking God to give you a hunger and thirst for his righteousness and asking him to give you a spirit of repentance asking him to give you just a desire for him.
I believe that God has sovereign over all things and I believe that the only way that I can desire him is if he gives me that desire for him otherwise I can't desire him so pray for that ask for that desire and that hunger for him and and then act on it you just say Lord what do you want me to do do I want to read my Bible board or do I will need to listen to good sermons what do I need to do to keep my head space safe in.
And and focus on you throughout this journey that I'm on that we call life and that might look a little bit different for a lot of us but that's that's how we give it to God it's a daily struggle and and we all have different fleshly sins that we struggle with on a daily basis and when those who are up have people in your life that are that you allow to be close to God.
You allow to be close enough to you that's just that could say hey Kevin how's your relationship with the Lord today because you're really upset about this thing that you do know that this isn't God's plans to don't you that can confront you on these things.
Many of us it's really easy to to claim a relationship with God but then when difficult things come up we literally it's evident to everybody else that whoa this person maybe needs some work in that spiritual piece of their life that's okay it's really good it's really okay when you recognize that you need some work in that piece of your life because that's really what's really good.
Spiritual maturity is I've always said spiritual maturity isn't that you don't sin spiritual maturity is the definition of spiritual maturity is that you're quicker to recognize what you do sin so that you can ask for God for forgiveness and repentance.
You're going to sit on a daily basis and that's a given but if I go days and weeks wallowing in in a sin that I'm not repented of it's definitely going to push me farther and farther away from God and we allow these these wedges to be driven at our life through circumstance and through at all.
Our own flesh that allows it and we need people in our life that will confront us and speak the truth to us so that we stay on track so I'm not trying to try to get out of these zoom calls and jump on a soap box and preach at you I preach it myself i said daily in the thought and action and I need to repent daily for that and that's how I keep my relationship with him.
Closer and asking him for a hunger for his word asking him for a hunger for the truth and that's the only way I can it's not out of my works and how holy I am and how great I am because I read my Bible every day that could be meaningless works of flesh itself we have to be dependent upon him.
And his grace to overcome everything that we're going to be challenged with in this earth and I realize that i'm talking to a bunch of people here that have cancer.
And i'm in the same situation as you and it is just daily like hey Lord i'm just trusting in you for this to I got to do everything that I think I should be doing and that I have peace doing here's another question people ask me this all the time.
Well, should I get this therapy should I do this therapy should I go do I be vitamin C should I go do hyperbaric therapy should I go down to Mexico should I go here we have to be very careful people that we're not running to and fro and.
And losing all knowledge or the truth we have to be very careful of that because we live in a society that you can do those kind of things.
You can you have the money to do those kind of things maybe there's danger that's involved with that when you have the money to do all these different things and try all these different things.
We can easily lose that dependence upon Christ that we're supposed to have when you have nothing and and you're sick and you're you're really really ill it's a lot easier to depend on Christ because you feel like you have nobody else to hold on to the praise God that you.
That we can sometimes get to that point so that we're broken so that we do you know realize that's the level of dependence that we're supposed to have on Jesus Christ but truthfully we're supposed to have that level of dependence all the time and many times our head and our desire to to have what we want to get what we want to have it now whether it even be health.
Can get in the way of that relationship and that dependence that we're supposed to have that really that's only place we're going to find sweetness and peace and true joy and true love and true contentment in our life is in that kind of relationship and we could look at scripture and the apostle Paul how.
And John and Peter sitting in their cells in a Roman jail where there was probably rats running across their feet and they had to you know use the toilet.
You know 12 inches away from where they were chained up in and then and it was stinky evil sickness and they could sing songs and praise even in those situations thinking it's very well that they could die and ultimately Paul did die in a Roman jail after you know being killed but he never got out of the jail and yet he still he never ever complained.
About how awful the jail was he only you know that's where he wrote all the epistles for crying out loud it's it's not our situation that brings us down it could be awful difficult struggling situations that can drive us to him and praise God for that I mean seriously you some people all this call right now could be literally died of cancer you have to go praise God.
I could have got hit by a truck six months ago and be dead and in hell praise God that he's given me the opportunity to to use this cancer to drive me to his feet and drive me to repentance.
What a loving God I have that he loves me so much that he is using this cancer to purify me and that's my prayer for all you that use that God uses difficult times whether it's cancer whether it's the death of a loved one whether it's a loss of a job whether it's you know financial collapse that that you allow God to use difficult times to purify you of the idols in your life.
And drive you to him in a greater level of dependence on a daily basis so you're more and more dependent upon him that's what spiritual maturity is that I'm more dependent upon him this week that I was two weeks ago I still fail all the time but I'm more dependent upon him this week that I was two months ago and that's that's what giving up for him giving everything up to him.
He'll hand in it over to him doesn't mean he's going to have not have you use your life take your supplements eat right take care of yourself but he's does not want you to make an idle out of those things that sin and some maybe not on this call but some people need to repent to that because that's idolatry and we're not supposed to let anything even curing our cancer get in between us in our relationship with God.
And you just need your repent of it and trust him in these things and i'll be honest it's evident sometimes in my life but it's evident sometimes in your life when I talk to some of you on the phone and you guys are a total panic mode.
And it's not i'm just trying to be a loving brother to you.
You need to you need to make sure that healing your cancer is not an idol in your life as much as I need to to make sure that have a life go back to normal that we don't live in a communist country as an idol in my life that's what God needs to do to the United States to drive people to him and to ultimately save them.
Some then i'm willing to go through that hell I need to be as a believer to to see that happen so sorry about preaching to you but that question did come through so.
All right, anybody with questions after that I didn't want to discourage you to ask questions but next question i am using 5000 i use a vitamin D am a pia but my blood tests for vitamin D still only shows 45 why is this so low.
And another blood test total vitamin E was 75 which is combination D3 and D2 i don't know i'd have to look at those blood tests and see what the difference in those if you can send those to me I would want to look at those a person can have vitamin D3 receptor defects and you don't.
So you don't absorb vitamin D well and you don't over at the salad you end up flushing them out with flushing it out fast that could be another issue to some people could be taking a lot of vitamin D and their vitamin D levels don't rise very quickly and that could be a piece to.
You ever need to reprogram the right after your initial program yes sometimes we do so.
Well often when we do a cheek swab recheck will test for that if you want to make sure make sure that we test for that make sure in your cheek swab request form you put in there please check for new frequencies for my right.
And we'll do that we don't always do that it's only if the person is you know if the person is doing worse or something like that we don't always do for that because there isn't any cost to that to do the program because that takes another hour or a half or so to do.
So but please just put that in your notes or ask you know email your liaison that that's something you want checked we can do that next question if we're running programs other than our custom programs how do we program the right to run two different programs consecutively.
That's more than we could really go over on the zoom call there's a way of stacking programs and then creating a new program but I can't really tell you that I just to show you how to do that on the right so it's a little tricky it's not hard to do.
it's not hard to do I think that there might be a video might get true right might have a video on how to do program stacking you could check their YouTube account they might have a video that does that can we use ozone to kill mold and pathogens without any negative effect to the tumor.
so we've covered ozone the last three or four zoom calls and there's positives and negatives to ozone and so if you want to do that I mean definitely if you have mold issues I would say I would go for it if I was you.
mold can be really nasty and causing other issues and certainly so I that would be something that I would consider strongly if I have mold.
occasionally I have a false out spelling fluid coming from my belly button area I was told this was due to detoxing is this true.
it can be yes it can be so that is possible if there is fluid coming out your body I would I think I should have a conversation with you a zoom call conversation so that I could go into more depth.
Michelle commented it if you highlight or select up to three programs in the same folder and then press run it should run all the programs in a row if they're in the same folder so I don't know how you do that in general folder Michelle maybe you can clarify that I've never tried that interesting.
learn something new every day so she said it's the same day as long as you're not going between multiple folder so in the in the general right program.
health a medical folder I mean it's what's not in the folder itself it's in the whole alphabetical if you highlight.
each one of those but you have to go into it here so how would you do that.
Hey sorry I didn't realize I can unmute myself can you hear me okay yeah so so yeah so in the general true right frequencies if if you select true right frequencies.
in that folder and then it opens up and then you'll see all of those initial folders and then tons of programs and alphabetical order after that.
you can select three programs and they don't have to be in consecutive order just the way that you would select all three is to do I believe it's command so you might select accelerated healing and then.
scroll down a little bit and then you'll see you know flew and then just command select that once and I you've got both of those selected.
scroll down a little bit further hit command select a third program you've got those three programs now selected within the main true right frequencies folder hit run.
and that should queue up all three of those programs in a row.
beautiful thank you a shall appreciate that you're welcome yep.
okay if there are any other questions we will bid to do for today thank you for this will be recorded now all our zoom calls are going to be recorded.
and if you need a copy they will be saved as not to the public so we can directly email you a link to it that you'll be able to use but they will eventually be in that back office that membership area that i'm creating.
and we're still out at least a good month before that will be done so.
but I think that'll be a nice addition that will be another nice added thing that we can use alright everybody i'll be praying for you I pray that you'll be praying for us and.
have a great.